salut à tous alors on se retrouve
toujours avec ce match là pour donner un
mcdonnell et et on va regarder
peut-être la partie une des parties les
plus aboutis de la bourdonnais un petit
chez de 20 donc c'est parti mcdonald's
avec les blanches sont eux quatre
habituels et new look élire trois donc
au lieu de son cou et 4 déjà vu pas même
le parti là dessus et la bordeneuve a
pour enjeu sa variante de la cécilienne
avec ce e5 qu'on appelle la kalachnikov
mais ça peut ça pue la vente de la
bourdonnais bien évidemment alors l'idée
des noirs là dessus c'est simplement
fait de prendre un peu le centre camille
ton développement comme on attaque ce
cavalier et et pose une question aux
blancs donc l'idée c'est de oui c'est la
lutte pour le contrôle du centre on sait
maintenant que les blancs doivent jeu
qui avait 5 pourquoi parce que le cac va
donc y attaquer il faut faire quelque
chose alors plusieurs choix soit calé
processes comme dans la partie mais le
défaut ce qu'on ramène un pion de la lgv
est recentré donc les noirs ou en vie si
peu de jeu des cinq et créer ce duo
central très fort donc pas forcément
reconnaît qu'elle prend 6,6
même si c'est pas si mauvais que ça mais
voilà le problème section les coudes
retrait du cavalier par michael bay 3 ou
cavale et f3 les noirs ont joué cali et
6 et surqualifiés 3 pour défendre le
pion fait foot b4 on la tacc encore et
encadre défense passive comme fou
detroit alors des 5 et les noirs se
libère voilà faut savoir que dès qu'on a
ce genre de structure déclinant à la
sphère des cinqs et c'est très bien pour
eux donc c'est pour ça que les blancs ne
doivent pas jouer passif comme ça et
puis tout jouer des ventes avec tous ces
quatre qui t'a donné l'option 4 un jour
et chercher à pêcher en eaux troubles
mais pareil c'est pas à 100 c'est
vraiment
clémente avantageuse ce qu'est l'e3 que
les baies 3 retour l'autre coup qui ya
ses cavaliers f 5 ans donc ils veulent
revenir vers des 6 ou 7 au pied vers 3
avec l'autre cavaillé là et joue sur le
trou vu comme ça c'est pas bête mais les
noms des cinq qui les libère j'en prends
il faut prendre ici et et voilà llodra
ce genre de final qui est quand même
pareil pour les noirs donc on comprend
aisément pourquoi
quel et b5 ici et jouer et donc ce
qu'ils mènent dans laquelle schenker
c'est le coût des six voilà vous en a
beaucoup parlé que mathieu dans votre
livre et sur décision voilà pour priver
les blancs cette case mais il y au
dessus des coups comme assistent sont
jamais vous laisse les blancs venir en
échange et on veut faire d'un epci ce
soit les blancs dans une finale soit il
retire leurs dames et une heure soit au
fond dames g6 pour attaquer le cadre
gêner les blancs un peu soir
développement et ses 1
ce sera une option mais bon moi j'ai
toujours préféré plutôt jouer des six
dans cette position hélas les blancs
mesure de grandes options soit se
développer et c3 soit joue un peu
étonnant aussi avec ses 4 voilà bon si
vous voulez découvrir tout ça il y aura
peut-être d'autres vidéos à l'avenir
vous pouvez regarder les bases où il ya
les livres bien évidemment un bon
toujours est-il dans la partie mcdonnell
a pris ans et 6 jan aps rend fou c'est
quatre cavaliers 6 est en fait peut-être
qu'il est trop envie de d'éviter des
saints qui est juif ou g5 qui bon
jouable mais pas génial en fait je veux
dire que rock est sûrement le mieux ici
parce que des cinq trop vite n'est pas
bon
faut penser à se développer et des cinq
noms un peu trop vite le jeu sans être
prêt n'est pas en vrai pions prendre qui
comprend foulée 5 et shaq va faut courir
ou 17 prises d'un an prend part au tour
un état croupion ou des six le défend et
bien encore floues g5
on veut prendre le cavalier du coup
prendre l'option après est et nord tout
de suite sont sous pression au centre
donc on pourrait pas jouer des cinq si
vite après petit rock faudra le préparer
et faire prendre
fawcett ce qui est possible et du coup
les blancs préfet recueilli 6,3 en très
petits rats qui met peut-être avec les
noirs on va pas les affaires des cinq
bons repas en prod changer deux des six
tours b 8 soit foule aussi soit
peut-être le fond beyssade prépare à
dessein 15 jours pourra créer une partie
mais d'un point de vue théorique mieux
pour le blanc de jouer le jeu comme ça
il a fait bouger 5 donc il lui faut
cette dame 2 et il lui a fait quand même
quand même des cinq ici le truc c'est
qui je pense va jouer d'amener dans
l'espoir de récupérer ce pion le pain
parce qu'un papillon prend puis on prend
foulée cinq échecs on court avec fouille
des sacs donc le fruit attaqué en k2
dames 35 et surtout prenez ça ton peut
reprendre le cavalier qui couvrent qu'il
est champion
donc les noirs aura ce fort centre et
une position préférable alors sur des 5
il a fait quoi il a pris un f6 vous
prend vous b3 petit rock mais bon voilà
on va dire que verture est passé on a
joué dix coups et quand même que je
pense tout le monde choisir et noir
d'accord avec moi puisque on al'avantage
de la paire de fou on a le centre voire
des pièces plus active et ses îles petit
rock
il a fait à 5 pas mal joué là c'est
parce que
on peut vouloir fermer le flou et
surtout aussi je veux choississent faire
une enfilade donc ses pions prend ok
puis on prend tour des 1 il s'en sort
pas mal parce que ils contre attaquent
le pion il enlève sa tour de f1 il faut
être sur le final donc tout ça pas mal
des quatre côtés nord donc bah ouais on
sauve le pion comme ça et là d'un coup
un assez mauvais stratégiquement il a
joué ses quatre bons même si je veux
dire la pression on sait déjà pénible et
c'était mieux de jouer un coup comme je
sais pas si les deux sur conan sûrement
quel jeu foule essaie t on c'est bon
voila voila tout langage des noirs ces
messieurs à la paire de fou il ya cette
diagonale là bas et c'est pas mal pour
les noirs se prêter à des attaques
ensuite joué dans un truc comme g6 rouge
et 7 ans le bon droit et ils vont
pousser la marée de pions quand même les
noirs sont mieux mais bon rien foutu
mais en levant ses quatre bombes à le
problème c'est qu'on donne l'option
passé qui est protégé sa foi lance un
jour on va pas arriver à bloquer les
pions et là en fait ouais on serait plus
de problèmes que qu'autres choses avec
ses 4 donc faux pas à rajouter des
problèmes qu'on a déjà
alors il a fait un bébé 6 pouces et 2
donc attention bien sûr d'aller prendre
cription ce qu'on se prend plus proches
cet échec mais il affaiblit cette
kabylie deux tours à huit passes ses
pièces au centre c'est bien qu'ils
allaient ligne 6 donc il est bien placé
mais bien sûr vous dit de pas mal dans
neuf le fou et on est prêt à lâcher ses
skis avait dans la foulée ses cinq de
ses six f 3 bon il se bat bien calmes
avec les blancs il fait une bonne série
de coups fawcett retour parce qu'ils
voulaient pratiquer des six qui arrive
et est ce un clin d'oeil ces quatre
ouvrages suite x 4 donc c'est les blancs
qui font finalement une enfilade
mais même si là il ya une qualité
le problème ça va être leur poids
puisque nous pressons le fruit indiqué
donc il faut le sauver ou contre
attaquer c'est ce qu'il a choisi de
faire ici
donc si jamais si jamais le poussant à
la je sais pas on va dire un petit coup
de pouce ou 17 avec les noirs on va
pouvoir jouer certains ou trois donc le
droit à partir va partir au coin et on
va pas reprendre ici et quoi faire
maintenant parce que pions pranger de
ces la menace si les blancs prennent et
ben y'a comprend ses mates et je dois
dire en fait ça va juste être maintenant
donc le var est en train tout comme tour
g1 kyi qui défend à peu près on peut
nous prendre prendre pour prendre cette
tour et puis aussi d'options à madame la
tour tout le monde pour pour mater même
tour ici et le roi blanc ne va pas
survivre longtemps donc beaucoup et
c'est ça le problème dans cette position
après après 34 c'est que les noirs ont
le choix attaquer et qu'à cette menace
de dames 3 si on prend etc
mais il trouve trouve une bonne petite
idée il fait ses six donc contre attaque
et il enlève aussi se fourrer qui était
hyper important pour être tous prendre
là bas et il vient je comprends et 3
quand même hélas les trois mon coup de
défense fait deux tours ces deux pour
défendre la seconde rangée pouvoir des
cases
est-ce que sur fion prend ça à peu près
les mêmes thèmes que ce qu'on a vu de
maths ici avec ce tour kings 2 donc bien
sûr sirois h1 il ya donné 3 mg de nattes
donc le roi dame n'est en rien mais ça
n'a pas beaucoup les aider puisque ont
fait tomber deux ans avec un milkshake
le roi s'en va échec et mat ici donc ça
ça marchait bien aussi
donc comprennent trois tours dans ces
deux très bien joué et on défend la
seconde rangée dame eu trois échecs
et là il a fait une erreur il à faire ou
à agen
et quand j'analyse et apparemment c'est
quand même mieux de faire tour f 2
dans cette position même si sage du jeu
honorable et où va cette affaire en fait
tu vois cette affaire il nagera chain
montbel sont fous les blancs aussi f2
maintenant donc menace éventuellement du
but damien externe
enfin même pas éventuellement menace
d'un homme tout court enfin multifoot
rang ou fait demain la dame de revenir
on prend ça me surprend hop on fonde à
muttur les pions matin ok donc touré fin
du cours des trois attaques la tour
prise prise le 4 et là on voit que trio
de pions qui avance est quand même assez
pénible ça prend à la gorge les blancs
tam s'est vite donc il veut faire
éventuellement des trois fuites vont
ensuite et des huit dames comme ça ça ne
dévierait se fout des 8 mai ils couvrent
des jouets dame ses quatre tours
dames 1 on s'en prend la toile f1 tour
c'est un donc pour l'instant ça défend à
peu près mais dans les pionts conçu
d'avancé ça c'est le problème
dams et cinq bons mètres la tour en
fuite
il l'a sauvé on assure attention 11.8
mater la mena sans tarder un donc
constant tout en place mieux 3 et des
pions continue à avancer à la masse
osseuse il ya eu 2 et 3 et il a fait de
me prendre et bien jouer autant
reprendre un vieux de la veille abandon
mais quelle belle position finale parce
qu'elle est large gamme cette file à dam
mais bon ces triplés sont beaucoup trop
fort on à ses fins en un seul un bastion
prendre trop thion partout et sa bande
mais jolie partie vraiment bien mené
c'est tout centrale ses pions qui ont
avancé une des petites combines tactique
tout ça c'était pas mal donc voilà
j'espère vous avez apprécié et on se
retrouve bientôt au revoir